we are grilling mark wahlberg about his  celebrity doppelganger when was the last  time someone mistook you for a Matt  Damon well now people just do it to bust  my chops you know if it happens I don't  try to correct people they're like I  love hearing four and you're like thank  you Mark transforms into real-life hero  Mike Williams an oil rig worker who  helps save lives during the massive BP  oil spill in 2010  how does market into a character like  like mine this man can do a lot of  amazing things amazing things like doing  his own stunts  making a 70-foot jump off an oil rig but  how did Mark convince Mike to be a  consultant on deepwater horizon he'll  promised me an underwear day oh my god  Oh stoically  what's happening with that it's  happening